[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much thank you so much to
the Academy we're so grateful for this
I brought my crew here this is writers
among the herd berry an oxonium producer
you wondering strong GP cinematographer
near Aspen also there are four students
back at home hopefully watching this in
the early morning in Sweden Robert
Krantz editor and Lyndall sound designer
abolutely post-production coordinator
and Andrea's AM composer and we want to
thank the rest of the team and the
actors champion Miriam and all the
others and I want to thank my teacher
ylva Gustafson and my mentor Tomas
Alfredson and everybody else at the
Stockholm University of the Arts and I
want to thank my mom and dad and my
brothers are on and you will thanks to
them I grew up watching films and that's
the way we all grew up and that's the
way we learned about the world by
watching films and lots of them were
from here in Hollywood and we made this
film to beg together based on our own
experiences of the pains of growing up
but also film about what it's like to
grow up today since the introduction of
social media the way we talk to each
other the way we communicate the way we
influence each other the way we learn
about the world has changed and cinema
should be here to reflect that and
that's why we worked so hard for more
than a year to tell this story and
that's why we're so so thankful and
happy and grateful to the Academy for
being here and for giving us this award
thank you so much
[Applause]